to the losers we made an oath I swear
if it isn't that if it ever comes back
we'll come back to you we didn't stop it
so first of all you obviously have your
younger counterparts playing you in this
movie it was 27 years prior wanted to
ask you if we were going to go jump
ahead 27 years if there was gonna be an
in chapter 3 who you would like to play
you're the older version of you and I
have light suggestions if you yesterday
we had talked maybe wouldn't someone ask
this question I mean there I don't think
there should be in it chapter 3 because
we're finished with that book and I mean
I would i I mean I just don't think you
should but if there was [ __ ] Spacek
good would be a that's a good one I
thought of at the top of the head
Richard Gere yes I liked that I had her
you had Dennis Quaid and Kurt Russell
Jessica for you I had Jessica Lange Mia
Farrow or Julie Andrews would not be on
a horror version a horror music musical
you know sitting around this table you
guys had to have you had this dinner and
you got to reflect a lot in this film
about the younger version of yourself
your when you were younger and you were
the young losers age who did you idolize
like who did you grow up wanting to be I
saw something your Instagram like a
clown costume yes as a clown yeah I mean
I but I never saw the I didn't yet based
off Pennywise know but it was it was a
doppelganger good my mom did my makeup
so good Wow
she knew um I'm trying to think I mean I
liked Alyssa Milano she was on who's the
boss and I thought she was really cool
and I was kind of a nerd so I was like
she's rad and then I surely and Andy
knows this about me I was obsessed with
the New Kids on the Block obsessed and
Joey McIntyre I thought I was going to
marry him when I grew up I bet my sister
$1,000 of that money too late now she's
taken
I dreamt of you
[Music]
I missed you
we obviously see the younger version of
yourselves in this film if we were gonna
do an it chapter 3 27 years from now who
would you like to play an older version
of you Oh Judi Dench love it perfect
answer that Dame 27 yeah wait I have
such a light suggestions if you can't
think of any more light suggestion white
suggestion oh wait suggest very curious
about this okay
Andy for you I have gary oldman and
rufus sewell you know what Forest
Whitaker at Danny Glover Andy Garcia or
Michael Douglas Michaels I have no upper
lip that's why that's why Michael
Douglas doesn't have another lip either
Hannah and I just wait Jack Nicholson
for you oh that's cool that's cool
he's a yeah that'd be great can you
please give me one or two I think you
nail I think you nailed it I would have
gone Harry Dean Stanton I would say he's
too old I a Gary Busey Gary Busey's you
know and I would you know you'd like to
see the area Busey his family I've never
alone and then I would have got Jake
Busey as Eddie I just like Delroy Lindo
he just he's like yeah that's like he
makes me laugh every time like so bill I
heard that in the dinner scene it was my
favorite scene in the movie I love the
chemistry between you guys I heard that
Andy was sort of giving you a dirty
dancing Pat yeah yeah they call it is
that Patrick Swayze English
yeah how does the directors like direct
you if he doesn't speak know he does a
good job II does a lot of movie
references like that anything I'll do
Patrick Swayze yeah I picked up James
McAvoy like Jennifer Grey and then we
had a very graphic sex scene on the
table very long graphic incredibly
awkward no music no no no they just like
Andy wanted to go a different way with
it and then it got really disturbing
yeah and then James was just like crying
a little bit
no no no he was liking it no no no I'm
[Laughter]
obviously there's younger versions of
you in this film who and you guys were
their age did you idolize and sort of
want to grow up to be Michael Dukakis
no no their age I remember said River
Phoenix was really cool remember River
Phoenix was in a movie called night and
life with Jimmy Riordan and the girl I
had a crush on her name was Christie
coffee and she went and saw it and she
was like oh my god she's so cute and
then he was an Indiana Jones and I
started it and then he was in stand by
him and he wasn't same I mean before all
that and I was like that guy is cool I
will never be as cool as that guy i I
didn't younger I'd there wasn't really
anybody that was but I know when I was
like in college like I thought Donald
Faison was like the funniest food in the
world and clueless so so I said I still
think he's funny he's over I was like
more musician stuff Axl Rose but that
ended up not being Bonnie Raitt yes
hallo I love Bonnie I was such a J I was
such like a gem carrot then when he came
out like with all those movies and then
couldn't get enough it's me the losers
club is officially begun
[Music]
we didn't do this but we have to stick
together all this time I mean you've
been playing these characters now I've
never seen anybody do either a penny
wise impression or I've never seen
anybody do an impression of your older
counterpart can you do either Isaiah I
feel like I am you're one of the same so
he'd be like oh yeah oh yes oh that's
really good yeah one do Billiken our
walk the plank
no he does that all the time oh my oh
yeah also that CGI they could've just
aged us no easy obviously man what I
kind of have a question along those
lines for you guys like I'm sure you get
told you look like people is there any
sort of sequel reboot or remake that you
would love to sort of take on that's a
great question question I already know
you know I'm trying to think of a really
good old movie that deserves like alien
you can do yeah I think alien would be a
really fun environment like kind of set
to the young because the set designs are
so cool and yeah they just like make the
world even better and being on those
sets would probably be pretty spooky did
you come up with one I like to be in
like a biopic yeah Bill Hader I don't
know there's a bunch of people you're
just saying I think if you know who
could be a Beatle yeah that would be
beyond amazing
yeah yeah okay yeah nothing cool I'd do
Muhammad Ali for sure oh my gosh that'd
be a lot of fun you would kill it that
would be so cool I picked Edward
Scissorhands for you oh that's such a
nice thing
thank you I love them I just watched her
recently and it's so sad it is it's one
of my favorites but yeah put it out
there
yes um so you guys wrote letters to your
adult counterparts
was there one sort of I know you've sort
of talked about it but you haven't
really said what was in your letter what
was sort of like your shining moment
that you think and I know you sent bill
a picture of yourself and he refused to
put it on his man I did send a picture
of myself as Warner Brothers what was a
Warner Brothers have a picture of us and
it was like frame it was all pictures of
us framed oh yeah and e-beam not one -
yeah it was like weird having a child's
picture is that your son why is there a
picture of Finn wolfhard in your trailer
like I don't know so yeah they didn't go
for it and I don't blame them it's
pretty weird
but um yeah I said something like um I
hope you're enjoying Hollywood or
something like that you're famous and
stuff so it was in character yeah I love
that I love that um for me because
because Mike is such a sweet guy but he
was raised to kind of be a loner in a
sense I told him of course you have to
be smart and be strong and be wise but
still let yourself have fun you know
because you need that friendships your
crew I didn't I don't really remember
anything in particular I just remember
kind of writing about staying strong and
staying with staying with the friends I
made during that summer yeah
you guys actually made me cry in the end
of this movie oh thank you for the first
I know I know imma try to try so last
question um the adult version got a
dinner scene that was kind of epic and I
know you guys will see it tonight it's
the opening scene of the movie if you
guys as a cast got to have a dinner
scene what one actor would you bring to
the table oh that's great question the
other good quick and e-beam or something
like that
oh okay yeah no that'd be cool yeah it
would be cool you're right it would be
cool I don't know um like you searching
for him in my eyes and I like chosen you
go I would invite you I wanted by Remy
malli
oh I feel like that'd be a very
interesting interesting dinner
I wouldn't like Keanu Reaves
[Music]
it consumes us from the inside until we
don't have a choice okay so first of all
you guys your older counterparts have
the task of sort of emulating you guys
if you can any of you do an impression
of your older counterpart or Pennywise
okay go done the Royal Exchange is a boy
band rolling stones totally boy Ben I
know a bunch of conspiracies I'm like
and indulge cuz it's gonna waste my time
and I don't have time to eat like use my
brainpower right now well he's from New
Zealand so he's fine he's accents all
over he's like you don't really know who
it's from businesses accents always if
they talk to you very quiet but he has a
jacket on next year after he's Irish
also mini I didn't imitate but also just
cuz also hard to imitate you can take
our hearts Justin you want just you but
like thank you well done um so I know
you guys wrote letters to your adult
counterpart was there sort of one thing
that you're particularly proud of so I
don't think you've ever really said what
you wrote um I kind of went over the
fact that bill should not feel guilty
when he comes back to Derry that he's
cuz he he he's kind of defined by his
guilt in that he feels about his brother
and he feels responsible about forcing
like Stanley and and and his friends to
go into the sewer but I wanted to make
sure that when he goes up he doesn't let
that put him down that he
kind of goes past that and goes come his
own person it's like for easy
that was beautiful I know you made me
cry in the movie you guys that I feel
like I'm like I might I might cry I
might cry again so the older um cast got
a dinner scene in this movie yeah you
guys didn't have your dinner scene but
if you got to have your dinner scene you
could invite any person to join the
dinner scene who would it be like any
person in the person Jim Morrison the
character Deadpool yes both okay
you could have them both exactly
terrible answer like Frank Ocean or
Franco shouldn't really tire the crater
and then real quick if you guys could do
a remake a reboot a sequel of any movie
that's been done in the other Jones and
I can play any joke and you got the Hat
yeah yeah yeah by Marion Hold'em I had
an idea hit me I'll come back I have an
idea okay famous I had a really good
think about it I forgot it was secret
I've always wanted to make a remake of
this thing but I don't know what it is
I'd like to do a remake of Shazam and
recast uh Freddie Mercury free me pretty
Sofia again pretty big and you got my
role I was always daddy's little girl
what about you
are you still his little girl Beverly
are you great to see you congratulations
on the movie um I heard Bill talked a
little bit about it it got very r-rated
his description of it but he talked
about haters skarsgård bill hater
yeah talked about when you guys do from
the dinner scene and you were telling
him to do a Patrick Swayze and oh do
dirty dancing here we go again
and he said but he said um he his
description was very r-rated but for you
why did that not make it in the movie is
he not does he not cut a rug is he not a
good dancer and and yet the Jabba the
Hutt impression made it in the movie so
what's on the cutting room floor can you
do a whole extended scene of Bill Hader
when you enter like this you know
whirlpool of improvisation you do more
than then you know that that it's gonna
end up in the movie you just don't know
what is gonna end up there or not so you
just do more and more and the truth is
that we're all human artists and we we
all get excited and sweep by the moment
so I got excited and I started like
throwing things to to Bill and you know
and he's he was game you know he's he's
incredible like the whole java thing he
brought he surprised me with that and
there was other deals of improvisation
for the montage of that scene yeah where
the where you know it has to be very
spontaneous and and we have to see the
losers having fun and catching up so
that's how one Tosh is like you accept
put out like an extended scene or
something I deleted or something in like
the extra you want to see Bill Hader
dancing like Patrick Swayze right that's
that's what you want yes I think you
will see it and super cut in the super
cut
yeah well let's talk about the super
got'em Joe you've been talking about it
but so will it be just a linear thing
like chapter one chapter two will there
be any sort of a mash-up between the two
sort of like energy intertwined no I
don't think there will be like you know
intertwined like in The Godfather
the Redux that they did this is gonna be
well we're still talking about it yeah
it's very early stages but it's gonna be
the two movies cut back to back with all
of the scenes that that were not
included is there something in
particular that was most important to
you that you were like I need to I need
people to see this oh yeah should I tell
you yeah so the most important things
are two scenes that I want to shoot that
you want to shoot yeah you haven't shot
yet I wonder I want to keep shooting I
want to include in this super gut I want
to include two scenes that are that are
very cool Wow
and those I can tell you is there a
possibility would you want to do a
prequel of course everything about this
world is fascinating and of course you
know I've been like speculating with
myself and and some people with Bill and
stuff but it's nothing that it's gonna
happen like right now
[Music]
this film when I compare it to the first
one it seems like for you guys from a
production point of view so many more
set pieces sort of there's just so much
more going on there was like an
underwater sequence with Jessica there
was the blood sequence there was even
like the de-aging I know the kids were
de-aged so for you from a producer's
point standpoint like what was the one
the thing that was the most challenging
the most challenging those are elements
I mean clearly this is a much larger
film yeah
greater scope more story elements we
knew it from the get-go we knew it as we
were finishing chapter one that in order
to finish the book the second part would
have a lot of meat most challenging was
to be completely honest schedule because
we had 15 very busy very talented stars
and in you know in the film and getting
them all together to do this was was
tricky the rest you know we have the
most amazing crew Andy is a very
knowledgeable director very creative and
and also flexible so there's always ways
to work things for I think for the
talent for our lovely actors it it was
you know it was a tough shoot physically
yeah and I don't like it a lot of them
didn't expect it to be right so so
physically demanding a lot of like
dramatic actors that I think I've never
been put in like a horror situation or
more of an action situation so yeah so
so I talked to Andy and he said you mean
I think everybody loves this world so
much the heat first one was a huge
success this will be a success I asked
him the possibility because I think
there's no I don't know if there's a
place to go with the sequel because it
wasn't written but he mentioned a
prequel did you make up for it
I'm up for anything that my brother was
that's the way we roll but we'll see
about that it's you know what would it
what I love is that we did something
incredibly special it's a book that I
read when I was 15 in my bedroom in the
neighborhood in where no say it is and
now we've just delivered the conclusion
of that book and I can't freaking
believe you're gonna make me cry and I
cried at the movie for you I mean
because you were a fan I mean - I can't
imagine what that would be like to be a
fan maybe the equivalent for me is
interviewing somebody I oughta lights
growing up but then working with Stephen
King
what sort of element about working with
Stephen are we both crying right now
yeah like tell me about this is that
that dream come true he's you know we
are the filmmakers that we are because
of him because we've read him when we
were little kids
and he taught us about humor and drama
and fear and you know we got to do
chapter 1 and we didn't know him and
then after chapter 1 well when we showed
him chapter one he sent Andy a love
letter you know saying how much he had
enjoyed it and and then he asked if he
could see the film again because his
grandson was graduating and that was
what he wanted for graduation gift to
see it
we started this amazing correspondence
then on chapter 2 we got to really get
to know him and he came to sat and said
this as our three four hours tops and he
stayed in Port Hope which is this tiny
town outside of Toronto two hours
outside of Toronto he stayed with us for
three days and I cannot describe what
this man is like the most generous kind
funny human being it's I'm in awe of him
and I will be until the day I die
you